Okay, the answer to this question which can
really be tricky is two possible combinations of the
alleles, let's take a look at why that is.
Remember just like before we were going to have our
first division and were going to separate our pairs of
chromosome two, so great we separated it them. Well
the alleles are already all connected here on the
single chromosome split, so, it doesn't matter what happens
with our chromosome fours in this case. We
could go to either side, it doesn't matter. They're
not going to change our allele combination, so let's
just even remove them altogether. Now, let's actually take
a look. Okay, let's split these, and split
these. We've got plus-minus combination, plus-minus combination for lactase
persistence in dwarfism, and then minus-plus of recessive
dominant combinations over here for lactase persistence in dwarfism.
So, that's two combinations. Okay. Let's go back
and see if we split them to the other
side. They went to different sides during the cell
division. Well, and then we split them again and
you'll notice that it doesn't matter. These alleles
are traveling together. In fact, it appears that these
alleles are physically linked together on the same chromosome.
This is a real problem for increasing genetic diversity.
Looking at the possible combinations of alleles
for just two different genes. We've now
cut the number of combinations we could
get in half. Because everybody's linked together on
the same chromosome. The cell actually has a solution to this problem to help
us maximize allelic variation and combinations. Even
when genes are linked on the same chromosome.